l'ogre de bois mao
l'histoire est écrite par madomé et les
dessins sont de hoarau n'a quelque temps
de ça la ola bas n'avaient un grands
carreaux de bois qui a fait boire à eau
dans le carrosse balle à las ventas
animaux ban a été tranquille
napper point rien pas gaza zone ya les
chaînes chelhot pour cause et chante et
raconte l'histoire y ait de l'année love
un petit vie gadiamb mais voilà pas
qu'un jour la débarquer il connaît
quelques tti sorte un gros un bel abbés
bête log lutter appel coup la goulotte
des grands grand ses bras son corps
était grand ses jambes étaient longues
comme bois de gaulle est quant à ses
pieds tu es tellement belle que jamais
lu dernière botnet un soulier même pas
ça va deux doigts de pied il marchait
tout le temps pas ta terre que tu es
obligé sa tête il dépassait la plupart
de banquiers de bois n'aurait dit un
petit coco coulé en l'air un match chaud
qu'à ce moment valait mieux méfier ses
yeux des comptes poignard son et et
pointu c'est dans des pareilles l'âme
coûte au locle à la casse le ti
l'ambiance la vie les animaux par le
fait d'un teaser sont qu'un danger cia
lui l'avait mange trois cochons marron
jourd'hui n dizaine macaques
il faisait pas peur à vue demain se
manquer quinze ou vingt lapins des
risques à passe par son gosier
banza n'avait plus qu'assez de voir
cette camarade faire gober zot comme ça
en plus on avait tous les horizons
imaginez que votre tour il tardait pas
pour arriver
martin futé le chef il avait fini à
haubourdin tafer compliqué ce moment la
lune avait beau gars de sa tête lui
trouvais pas rien ça servait lituanie
dans le vide ça qui fait lui la décide
faire un rassemblement avec son band
allons tout ensemble
ce manque et on va trouver quelque chose
boeuf moka la cause en premier allons
faire un pas pour metal est dedans par
d'inviter la main en alu et le malien on
a dans l'idée de faire sa meuf n'est pas
capable répondre les vraies luttes et
fort ce moment lui l'avait aussi peur
que les autres mac atl a dit la cape en
10 à lui envier aux grands pieds de bois
un cas peu de chance il va chapeauter un
bateau de son côté martin fit et la
balance la tête puis l'âme en alu et le
manière on a dans l'idée de faire ça m'a
4 la pagaille répondent les vraies
luttes et un as ou grimper selon lui
l'avait autant peur que les autres
souris sont aulas dît l'acadie galut à
force rires l'ue va finir par tout fait
art affûté l'ammonal elle quelle manière
on a dans l'idée de faire sa petite
souris n'a pas gagné répondre même si
elle y connaissait un tic tac un tas de
la malice elle n'avait autant peur que
les autres
toute la bande est obligé d'admettre que
dans tout ça l'avait dit n'avait point
rien de raisonnable préfère il fallait
qu'on tente d'autres ça ou qu ils
n'avaient plus rien à espérer
c'est là que les aigrettes la cause et à
cause de sa paroisse fantine la vieille
tortue et c'est la seule que le gros
loeb l'a jamais essaye attaquer il faut
dire aussi que sa pole est tellement
dure
sa coque départ et la corne si je
l'avais mangeas elle nourrirait sur son
estomac savez sur livret mammoth et en
plus de ça elle est toujours de bon
conseil
souvent qu el gaied à nous allons tout
de suite perd pas de temps cambon à
l'arrivée
sans tilter anglais sur un galet à
presov son vieux au soleil tout le pays
causée en même temps il faisait un
désordre pas possible doucement ma mây
me comprends pas ces jeunes enfants
raconté le chef y cause martin futé là
explique azote d'expliquer à l autre
grand fracas laisse à réfléchir toute la
bande la fameuse attaque et plus
personne ni bouger quand il a pris son
temps comme à son habitude et elle a dit
me pense qu'il pourra faire un affaire
où saute moins on a deux trois dalons
que va faire la sphère sommant de t'y
connais bon allez pas trop rapide
et puis il faudra attendre le bon
l'occasion prend un peu patience nous va
troubles bout de beuglant les animaux
auraient été contents connaître tout de
suite ça que la tortue n'avait dans la
tête mais elle n'a pas voulu dire à zot
son lit des bandes nahla en tournée
admis console et pas trop longtemps
après ça un après-midi de bonheur cela
entendu un énorme ronflements qui
résonnaient partout dans la forêt il a
arrêté un instant et a commencé
cauet c'est ça encore capable à
commencement de susa temps mais en même
temps
sautez envie de connaître que sap l'été
c'est ma méthode normale
un loup rôde et qoussaï les n'a pas
tardé à retrouver ses dégoûts l'afld
legros logue qui respirait la bouche
ouverts il était allongé sur un pitot
ces belles mains croisées sur son bel
vente
rex et lui ont tiré lula trop manger et
le gall pu lever les animaux y avant
cette précaution paraît populare y est
ainsi par mégarde le bloggie bougies un
doigt qu'il ait eu un brin de cheveux
mais non il dormait même voilà le
l'occasion dati attendait alors hop
fantine dépêcha zot laisse pas lui levé
tpo confère 100 m
que voilà parfois en chine qui arrive
elle n'est pas tout seul
un pad their nié y suivait l on avait
toutes sortes qualité des rouges des
verts des jaunes des noir et blanc des
gros
babouk des petits bib toute la bandit
balancé à droite à gauche
sus aux grandes pattes meg ça même la
trouvez-vous schaars un gros bébé doc
comme ça fanti on a commencé je crois
que la porte aux rotules a fait perdre
la tête et que je l'avais eu des médias
de confiance dans une vieille folle
pareil fipa la premi à première vue
marmaille mot bonne camarade grand pat y
travaillent sans fait désordre vite et
cet ouvrage est solide n'a pu borgna
dessus fantine la lance un petit signe
un la compagnie et la centaine dernier
l'accaparent le gros lot
depuis sa tête jusqu'à ses pieds en
passant par tous eu son corps soit la
maille à lui la maia lui un coup dessus
un coup de sous-payant commence la bande
d'animaux dépôt courbe atteint les yeux
leboube la retrouva les antilles et d'un
kilomètre fils collants
sortir n'est pas loin ça papa gueye
résister il fallait de tikrit bourges
aouda actrice à l'appui causer du tout
là on regarde le gros bout la famille
souk vos gars ça n'avait fait les
vallées ben non ils dos mais main
l'asus auront fait un peu plus fort
encore alors toute la bande la mettent
ensemble pour ou lebouc transformer en
gros saint-paul jusqu'au bord de mer là
où la ka palé lara lalliot large bande a
écarquillé les yeux pouvoir jusqu'au
dernier ait pu loin loin là bas quand il
comprend plus que ça le ciel que ça la
mer êtes la plus vue à rien le banc des
animaux l'a pris une grande respiration
l'âme et à chanter à danser
enfin the daily satipo verra comment se
vivent un peu dans un carrosse qui doit
tant par le bais glog ça que j'arrive à
lui après dans le milieu de la grande
mer eh ben ça c'est un autre histoire
on